If any of my children would be at a point...
...where they would just be begging me,...
"Why won't you just give up on me?"
I can't.
I don't know how.
There's no manuals for being a mom.
Yeah.
It's like you have to wing it, right?
And it doesn't get easier, you know.
It just gets harder in different ways.
High school was hard.
Really, really hard.
I know that my mom is always going to be there...
...no matter how much we fight.
It's like, the more we fight, the more we kind of bond a little, I guess.
Oh my gosh, I was so mean to you in high school.
Early middle age was hard.
My girls left at 18 and 19.
They moved far away from me.
Motherhood goes by very fast.
When you hold that little bitty baby in your arms,...
...it's just a love that you can't imagine.
My mom always made things happen for me, no matter what.
Mama was always there.
That's what she gave me.
Never give up on your child, even when they're driving you crazy.
And I want to be that for my girls.
Like, find it.